happy Star Wars Friday everybody so we
got some really cool new kylo Ren Rey's
stuff to break down and I'll explain a
couple really important dates we got New
Jedi costumes we got to talk about Rey's
parents Daisy Ridley said some really
pointed stuff that erased a whole bunch
of theories it actually gives her a
couple things in common with the Snoke
character at least with the way that
they were created Star Wars Day which is
coming up next week new footage stuff
dropping in an episode 9 Carrie Fisher
and Rian Johnson returning stuff so
let's start with the costume stuff but
there is a new brand of the Star Wars
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video it's just for a copy of the rogue
one blu-ray so if you ever wanted a
reason to buy a Star Wars video games it
would be to get a peek at what's coming
up in the new films because the
battlefront 2 Star Wars stuff revealed
what raised Jedi costume in kylo ren's
new costume is going to look like and I
know there was a bunch of people talking
about kylo ren's Skaar gaze stuff I'll
address that but it's not that big a
deal there was a funny answer that Rian
Johnson had he made a big change to the
way kylo ren's scar looks on his face so
if you remember back during force
awakens in their fight Daisy Ridley
slashed him and he had this big cut
going down the bridge of his nose
[Music]
so when we got to the last Jedi trailer
a lot of people were like hey wait a
minute
why does kylo Ren's car look so
different and he probably could have
healed that in a bhakta tank so there's
just a number of questions that people
had about the look of his face in
addition to his new costume so the
answer is that Rian Johnson said that
when they were filming the scar going
down the bridge of his nose just looks
stupid so I wanted to change it because
it looked weird which i think is the
find reason but you can see the costume
both his and raised just have a lot more
color Rey is slowly moving towards the
Jedi Brown which makes you wonder if
she's on the Luke Skywalker path from
going to relatively colorless costume in
the first movie to Jedi Brown in the
second movie and then winding up where
Luke Skywalker ended up in return to the
Jedi with like a full black costume you
go the whole gamut and another implies
there's a lot of darkness in the last
Jedi just because of all the red color
and the trailer in the way they did a
poster and there's even a crazy new
rumor that Luke Skywalker has been
keeping Darth Vader's Kyber crystal the
red crystal hanging around his neck in
kylo Ren really wants it so before I
address that big rumor just let me know
what you think about their new costumes
it just seems like kylo Ren is going to
be spending a lot more time without his
mask on because most of the pictures
we've seen him in relative to Episode
eight show him without it and it's even
smashed in the trailer so either it was
destroyed after his fight with Rey or he
destroyed it himself in his own rage
because it does seem like he breaks a
lot of his own stuff you just see him
destroying consoles left and right but
obviously he's dressed a lot more like
Anakin Skywalker was from Revenge of the
Sith
so I love how even though he's moving
away from Darth Vader because he's not
wearing that mask anymore he is still
very much trying to emulate the path of
Anakin Skywalker George Lucas never
fully explained why it was Anakin chose
these darker colors but visually it was
just meant to foreshadow what was going
to be coming for him like you all know
that he's turning into Darth Vader so
wouldn't it make sense that he'd have
some darker tendencies that would show
themselves in the way he dressed and the
things that he did the way he acted but
I think part of the reason why people
are so upset about kylo Ren in addition
to him being written in a really beta
way is the fact that he doesn't seem to
have a personality of his own he's just
trying to co-opt Darth Vader's
personality
like he's this young teenager who's lost
his way so he sees this iconic figure
that he finds out that he's related to
so he's like oh my god I'm gonna be just
like that I'm going to do exactly what
he did so you never really find out who
Ben solo was you only know who the faux
Anakin Skywalker Darth Vader is walking
around in this makeshift mask but if
you're not a huge fan of the character
the cool thing is is that Adam driver
did say that they would explore some of
his humanity so you'd find a little bit
about what's going on in his head during
episode eight even though most of the
focus has now shifted off of him on to
Luke Skywalker because people are like
what is going on with this crazy person
the Jedi need to end that is the
craziest thing that's ever come out of
your mouth but Luke Skywalker as a
raised father so that was one of the
biggest theories so we got to talk about
Rey's parents that's like the next big
thing that they kind of unofficially
revealed or at least cut a bunch of
theories out so a bunch of you messaged
me after they dropped the trailer they
did the big panel asking about these two
things like hey are they actually
confirming this so there was a later
interview that Daisy Ridley did that
I'll play in a second this was Josh GAD
making jokes onstage about trying to get
them to reveal who Ray's parents were
raised Skywalker Rey Kenobi are you and
Luke related by blood no to that one
okay are you a Skywalker is your name
Rey Skywalker
you can name Rey Kenobi
that's a popular on cleanest who doesn't
know neuroleptic so the important thing
to remember about that is that Star Wars
secrecy is so hardcore that all of that
is carefully choreographed they tell him
what he's allowed to make jokes about
before they go out there and I don't
think they let him make that joke if
there was even a small chance that Rey
was either a Kenobi or a Skywalker now
the interview that Daisy really did
provide some even better evidence so I'm
gonna play this clip here and then I'll
explain what that means so I was ringing
a little Lucas movement different from
like Luke's relationship with a builder
and well rain is not a teacher Yoda and
obi-wan are very much like guiding
students we hope they like Ben aronia
and Ray I probably he didn't even own
shears which turned up like weirdest
frickin lightsaber that you've not seen
in however long so so that in itself is
a big difference and then as things go a
lot I think there's a there's an
expectation there's always been an
expectation for Luke excuse me potential
you can do and what he should do much
likely right so in that sense they're
kind of similar but obviously the
dynamic is change because she's expected
something from him this time and it
remains to be seen with it you know how
he we asked about so I know it sounds
like she's making a couple offhanded
remarks about the initial meeting with
Luke Skywalker
he's never seen her before he has no
idea who are you
that does not sound like something that
a father who's being reunited with his
child would say at all who are you I've
never seen you before so that also means
that she probably wasn't a student at
his Jedi Academy the way they're
presenting Luke Skywalker's that he was
kind of a failure when everybody had
this big hopes for him after the Empire
fell but that's some pretty damning
evidence if he doesn't know who she is
and he has that crazy force connection
to his sister Leia he would know if she
had another child with Han Solo and she
were a solo so she'd still be part
Skywalker in that case but now it just
sounds like there's much more evidence
that she's a completely new character
that we've never met before that doesn't
mean that she's not related to someone
in the Star Wars universe it just
implies that she's not related to the
people that you would think that she
would be related to so the big thing now
that
has in common with the snow character is
that they both seem like brand-new
characters that you've never met before
in the Star Wars universe and even
though they keep reiterating that this
is very much a story about the Skywalker
family the Skywalker part of that story
looks like it's coming through the Ben
solo character so I know everybody
really wanted rate to be part of the
Skywalker family or even Obi Wan so you
had this really nice unbroken line of
Skywalker lineage from Anakin Skywalker
but most of that is flowing through the
Ben solo character in Rey just like the
MacGuffin the journal of the Wills
in the trailer is representative of the
new thing that they're bringing in the
new way they're headed so you had this
idea of just recycling old content
recycling old Darth Vader in Ben solo we
need something new something fresh so
practically during the plot of the movie
as well as metaphorically in the Star
Wars Expanded Universe like them
actually making these movies they need
to inject fresh things so you have the
Journal of the Wills helping
recontextualize Star Wars mythology
within the story and then you have the
Rey character the idea of someone new to
take that path this was all part of Mark
Hamill talking a lot about how it's not
Luke's story anymore and then Kathleen
Kennedy jumped down and was like but
Luke is still a very important part of
this but she didn't want him to downplay
Luke's importance in this story so the
Skywalker's are still a very big part of
the direction of the Star Wars Galaxies
is headed but you'll probably see once
they start announcing more spin-off
movies in whatever trilogy is going to
come next after episode 9 is that
they'll start moving past the idea of
the lineage of Darth Vader well let me
know just based on Daisy Ridley's
comments in Luke Skywalker not knowing
who she is
who do you think her parents are are
they completely new characters which is
what it seems like they're implying or
do you think it's somebody else inside
the Star Wars universe so I know you're
all wondering when we're going to see
new footage the next big Star Wars day
is may the fourth Star Wars day may the
fourth be with you they will definitely
be promoting Star Wars on that day but
there hasn't been any confirmation of
new footage I'm not expecting a new
trailer so they do drop new video
content it's more likely that it would
be behind the scenes stuff which is
still very revealing we learned a whole
bunch of stuff from the force awakens
behind the scenes real and d23 is
happening
this summer like the week or two before
comic-con happens and they'll probably
be presenting more Star Wars footage
they usually don't release that d23
footage to the public but during the
last d23 during a Star Wars year they
did Air Force awakens content so I'm
expecting them to do the same thing for
last Jedi and really like the last big
thing is episode 9 if you've been
reading about what's going on with them
developing the project Colin Trevorrow
who did Jurassic world is directing the
movie they're working on a different
treatment ryan johnson was originally
writing a version of the script but they
said that he's not involved with that
anymore he's just doing episode 8 in
Kathleen Kennedy just reiterated they're
not going to have some crazy trick to
try and work Leia into episode 9 so
they're going to do whatever they can to
honor her character and not completely
upset everyone that would just freak out
if they saw CG Leia in episode 9 so
don't worry about that but leave all
your requests for new Star Wars bonus
videos in the comments below because
next week is going to be Star Wars date
there'll be some extra Star Wars stuff
posting but there's some new Avengers
infinity Wars that I want to post
there's new American Gods and a whole
bunch more comic book stuff so while you
wait for that you can click here to
rewatch that Star Wars trailer and you
can click here for my non-spoilery
guardians of the galaxy to review thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight